so this is this is a this is stories
this is not this is it from The Wall
Street Journal take a look at this
picture we got Epstein and Bill Gates
Right There Jeffrey Epstein appeared to
threaten Bill Gates over Microsoft
co-founders affair with Russian bridge
player it is the lightest smallest grain
of sand effectively confirming I should
I I believe confirming the the
conspiracy the conspiracy theory that
Epstein was blackmailing powerful
individuals but they outright say it in
here they say in 2017 Epstein emailed
Gates and asked him to be reimbursed for
the cost of a coding course for this
young woman according to people familiar
with the matter now the issue here is
why would Epstein contact Bill Gates
about a young woman he had an affair
with in secret except to say I know you
had the affair I want the money
I know you had the affair they even go
on to say the intention was to Blackmail
uh Bill Gates in this so let me just
read and say
Jeffrey Epstein discovered that Bill
Gates had an affair with a Russian
bridge player and later appeared to use
his knowledge to threaten one of the
world's richest men according to people
familiar with the matter the Microsoft
co-founder met them in around 2012 2012
2010 when she was in her 20s abstain met
her in 2013 and later paid for her to
attend software coding school the email
came into the convicted sex offender had
struggled and failed to persuade gates
to participate in a multi-billion dollar
charitable fund that Epstein tried to
establish with JPMorgan Chase and that
whole story right there sounds like more
blackmail he went to JP Morgan and said
I want to get a bunch of the richest
people in the world to invest a hundred
million dollars into this fund and then
I get paid Millions out of it they say
the implication behind the message
according to people who viewed it was
that Epstein could reveal the affair if
Gates didn't keep up an association
between the two men now is this why Bill
Gates divorced his wife yes you think so
absolutely I think that I think that
when you're dealing with people that are
that wealthy and in the positions that
uh the people were in the one people
they went to Epstein's Island the
position that they held these people are
not motivated by money you know a couple
million here a couple million there Bill
Gates isn't going to notice but if you
threaten to tell his wife that he's been
you know porking some kid
that'll go ahead and get some compliance
and obedience out of them and that's
what it's I think that that's the reason
why Epstein's dead and I think that's
the reason why the list never came out
the people that have been to Epstein
Island because they're all probably
scummy people that have a lot that had a
lot of dirt or that I've seen had a lot
of dirt on them and that's what kept
them you know in line I think that there
are there are very powerful people that
have a lot of dirt on people with a lot
of money I couldn't help but notice in
that I think it was a PBS interview with
Bill Gates you see that one where it's
like well he's dead so you know I always
say but but here's the thing when he
goes he says she says did was did you
learn in a lesson here and he goes well
he's dead now so you know you always got
to be careful and he's like holding back
a smile and I'm like it's kind of weird
in later context to hear that Bill Gates
was being blackmailed by Jeffrey Epstein
and you go back to this interview where
he said he was asked if he learned a
lesson and seemingly for no reason it
says he's dead and so you got to be
careful as if to actually imply if you
screw with me you know what happens how
did this email come out with this data
it's a Wall Street Wall Street Journal
reporting so someone leaked it to the
okay someone they they it sounds like
they actually talked to people uh
who know Bill Gates and even got a quote
for from a spokeswoman for Bill Gates oh
they say Mr Gates met with Epstein
solely for philanthropic purposes having
failed repeatedly to draw Mr Gates
Beyond these matters Epstein tried
unsuccessfully to leverage a past
relationship to threaten Mr Gates a
spokesman four Gates confirming Epstein
was blackmailing him yeah
Bohemian Grove man this Epstein thing I
got a lot to talk this Epstein thing
really kind of it kind of like it's like
a tick burrowing under my skin I get a
call let's go yeah this is gonna get
hair you guys ready yes
this is like live YouTube you ready for
this I don't know if you guys right I
get a call about four years ago it's
from let's say a friend prior line of
work thing right
guy says listen and this guy who calls
me is an unimpeachable Source this guy's
not like some ham and egg or tomato can
guy throwing out some theory about a UFO
he saw 72 years ago whatever this is
like a legit no-nonsense guy
guy you trust with your you know wife
kid in car right
he says you know I got sent on a
temporary assignment once and on that
assignment I got sent out with the wcd
detail William Clinton uh William
Clinton detail
and uh I knew this guy well and he says
dan I I gotta share this with someone
he's like go on a plane and Bill you
know Clinton gets on the plane with this
guy and it turns out later the guys
Epstein now this guy I'm talking to this
Source he don't know who to you know
Jeffrey Epstein is he's just getting on
the plane doing the thing the whole you
know protection gig right
he says I get on the plane and there's
these girls who are obviously not of age
who are on this plane they're clearly
young these are not women these are
girls
and he says I see Clinton like disappear
into the back
with he goes I don't know what happened
I'm not saying what happened because all
I know is he disappeared and these girls
were back there or whatever and he said
they landed the next stop wherever it
was
and he goes up to the boss on the detail
and he says I I ain't getting back on
this plane because he's remember he's a
temp he's not so he's not used to like
whatever Clinton was up to with the
whole Shenanigans thing and this guy's
clear as the driven snowman he don't
want to mess around with this he says
whatever just happened back there like I
don't want any piece of it you know they
sent him home they sent that guy home
and he would never he's never tempted at
detail again now remember all those
blackberries on that detail here's
here's where the story gets super weird
the guy tells me
what is it months or a couple weeks
later when you lose property in the
Secret Service an email goes out to say
like hey I lost this phone and it goes
it gets logged into ncic or whatever it
is and everybody knows so basically if
you find this guy's gun God forbid his
phone it's now effectively stolen
property right all of a sudden all the
blackberries on that detail
for the agents start showing up like oh
this guy lost his BlackBerry holy
wow that's so crazy how'd that happen
I'm like no he says yes he says it was
the craziest thing like oh look agent
show me Bag of Donuts missing Blackberry
missing black bear this is around the
whole time like the Clinton thing's
going on so fast forward this story
right he tells me that about a year and
a half after that I'm in a green room at
Fox and I'm not gonna say who because
they didn't give me permission to share
it but well the short story but not who
they are says you know Epstein's a an
intelligence asset for people in the
Middle East right I'm like no I didn't
know that I'm like you sure that's
the person let's say is like I'm
absolutely sure of that that he's either
a witting or unwitting asset
intelligence asset meaning
his plane and that Island the cameras
there's a big assumption out there that
these videotapes were exclusively in the
custody of Epstein that's a huge mistake
the reason they wanted this story to go
away is because there's an assumption
like oh yeah Epstein had him no he
wasn't the only one who had him
according to his Source these assets
that's why this blackmail story makes so
much sense which Middle Eastern
countries they are I don't know but this
person who's a very very good reporter I
mean Aces right swore Epstein was either
a witting or unwitting intelligence
asset and they may have had his plane
wired up and they're the ones who have
all this stuff so the point is to sum it
up
how how do you know some of these
countries aren't going to some of these
power plays who aren't making decisions
because hey you wouldn't want this video
out there right how do you know 100 I
mean that let's let's get personal with
Mr Gates though if this is a story of an
adult man having adult relations with an
adult female outside of his marriage is
it the biggest deal in the world that
needs to be made public you know what I
mean what what I'm interested in is the
underage stuff the creepos that evidence
coming out I'm worried that they're
doing this with the Bill Gates thing as
like red meat like oh look oh oh yeah
and it's like it's not a criminal issue
it's a personal Scandal it's like oh wow
Bill Gates looks bad but what about the
Maxwell stuff what about the actual
Client List I don't think we should be
satisfied by what we're hearing and we
should obviously want more I think
you're totally right I think that the
actual crimes that they committed while
they are bad like I don't think that's
the worst thing that's going on I think
the like the things that they're being
blackmailed to cover up is probably
worse than the crimes they committed
well as bad as they are you know well I
was gonna say I think
the stuff that's that they're being
blackmailed to cover up probably is not
as bad as what they're doing yeah in
series is that what you're saying yes
yes right so like we hear a story about
you know prince Andrew and uh Virginia
and you're alive wow this guy should be
in trouble for that it's like what did
he do to try and hide that yes because
I'm I'm willing about a lot of these
wealthy guys did something 10 times more
evil or supported some real evil stuff
what does he know that someone else
knows that he knows that they're
threatening to go public about his let's
just you know molesting children you
know let's put it this way
you you you blackmail someone like Bill
Gates into giving up millions of dollars
to Epstein who then uses that money for
his trafficking purposes and that is the
the bigger problem these guys who are
like oh no my Affair could be exposed
better fund Epstein that's the crazy
thing here don't you find it weird too
that nobody seems to know what Epstein
really did no one else right it's like
oh they said he was a hedge fund guys
really what's the fun like the Joey Bag
of Donuts hedge funding nobody can seem
to dig up what this which brings it back
to your point like where was was that
what was happening was it some circular
like hey it'd be a shame if this got out
oh look a donation to your little thing
which he then uses to do I mean that
would be a really sick story even worse
than the original if they were funding
this stuff I think they were I think I
think like how else does this guy have
half a billion dollars a private island
and jets
I think the milk the asset thing makes
sense because one of the questions that
comes up from this is was he a puppet or
was he The Mastermind and I don't think
some former High School teacher was The
Mastermind I think he was the puppet
yeah I I don't know for sure I mean it's
an interesting there's interesting
questions around that but I I would lean
towards I'm Betty was I bet he was a
puppet and somebody else got away with
it oh yeah especially if this Middle
Eastern asset conversation holds water
that he's they're basically laundering
their money through Epstein and getting
him an island and a place to live and
funding his operation and then he's
getting Bill Clinton on an airplane and
getting him recorded having sex with
some girl that's not his wife well he
didn't do that he met this woman
apparently and then found out about the
affair and tried using that as leverage
against gates from this story We it
would seem the picture they're trying to
paint is Bill Gates never did the more
extreme things people are concerned
about that's why I'm like is this them
placating us hey leaked them a little
bit so that it seems like Bill Gates's
worst thing is that he cheat on his wife
it's called a limited hangout as opposed
to letting it all hang out a limited
hangout is where they only give you a
when like there's bad things going on
they tell you the truth about a little
thing or smaller things so that way you
can say oh we've told you all the stuff
blah blah but in reality they're doing
it to distract you from the actual big
thing women hang out versus letting it
all hang out and then when someone says
Bill Gates was on Epstein's plane they
go oh we know about that you know and
then and then Epstein blackmail over
that woman but she was she was an adult
I mean people from people aren't talking
about or people often forget the
connections that Epstein has with
politicians the clintons the you know
and and that's I think that probably has
a significant amount of substance as
well even if like Bill Clinton wasn't
banging little girls on Epstein's
Islands it's the connection that he has
in the influence look at how many people
were just dumping money into the Clinton
Foundation when Hillary Clinton was was
running and then it just like
disappeared and evaporated after she
lost no one really questions what was
going on with with that money with the
Clinton Foundation I mean I it probably
still exists but the connections between
you know politicians and Epstein and you
know I think that that's something worth
looking into and it blows my mind that
you guys We're not gonna get it listen
to this story right like what dirtbags
these people who run this country and
essentially run the glow bar do you ever
seem to like what scumbags like how do
you get on a plane with a girl that
looks 14 and a dude disappears in the
back and you're like hey you got popcorn
really like right what kind of sick run
this place Dee we're talking about
business Titans and nobody ratted this
guy out nobody was like Hey man that
looks kind of suspicious what kind of
losers are running this place wait you
want to Buckley say I'd rather have you
know the first hundred names in the
phone book than these people who run the
country United but he's so right yeah I
mean you look at the guy like in this
area we're in now where you get you know
middle class people with dirt under
their fingernails who you know leave
their work boots outside right these
people are a thousand times the man that
these losers who are worth fortunes and
have all this power who basically
facilitated this guy's BS I mean you'd
call that out in a minute you'd be like
wait wait wait calm down with this like
what's going on here and nobody ratted
this guy out thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time